the recent say about rattling from
Beijing have made preparing air raid
shelters a key part of taiwan's civil
defense strategy but as DW's Jerry Chan
reports not everyone thinks those
shelters are adequate
these yellow signs are everywhere across
Taipei they show the locations and the
capacity of thousands of Airway shelters
where people can hide in case of an
attack
now a smartphone app has been launched
that shows a real-time map so users can
quickly find the nearest shelter
officials want residents to get familiar
with these spots in subway stations car
Parks underground shopping malls and
even basements of private properties
this is one of the many car parks in the
city that can also serve as an airway
shelter however we cannot see any signs
of water or emergency supplies
and that is a problem
efficacy groups say many of these
shelters are very poorly equipped
Taiwan is hot and humid and car Parks
don't have any air conditioning and
there aren't sanitary facilities it's
not suitable to serve as a long-term
shelter
leads the civil defense advocacy group
Malaysia Taiwan Association
his organization regularly hosts first
aid and self-defense classes for the
public
apart from the lack of facilities Chia
is worried about the reliable access to
these shelters
many basements in these residential
buildings are occupied they might be
used as storage space and they're not
properly maintained or could even be
blocked
but what will happen in the worst case
scenario if China attacks
an analyst at the government fund
Institute of National Defense and
security research told us these shelters
are different from what many people
expect
practices
they are supposed to provide temporary
protection when an airstrike occurs
missile attacks are usually over a very
short time
three to four minutes
they might also go on for a couple of
hours
so facilities such as ventilation or
drinking water supplies are usually not
part of these shelter designs
the most important thing is that people
know where the shelters are Chen said
but many Taiwanese people have grown
numb to beijing's repeated shows of
Falls over the years so now the
government not only has to maintain
security facilities it also faces the
challenge of keeping up people's
vigilance